now live you have a beautiful British
accent but I'm asking poker players they
can show me another side to themselves
so can you do an American accent for me
American what I can do just your your
type of American accent not very well
what I prefer to do is come go down
south you know go down to Louisiana
where you know things happen down there
that well we can't always talk about but
um you know I live on the farm I got my
guns and sorry to go into some
stereotypes but I find it easier when I
when I'm trying to challenge you're
really Sarah grant right now Sarah grant
well damn
sorry sorry it's their hearings they're
hearing sorry Sarah herring yeah so I
mean I like to do that one um struck a
little bit with New York I have to like
think about my sneakers you know uh Long
Island um so I don't find that one that
easy but say Irish Irish Ireland well
it's again like I find when I get off
the plane in Dublin I have to listen
around a little bit and it's it's just
kind of a tricky one because I think I
my accident somewhere between Belfast
and Dublin but I prefer to actually go
to Jenny's burg to see a flicker where
there you know there's a lot of very
beautiful things we have the pill
ensberg national park the Kruger you see
the big five the Rhinos and so on so yes
a tefik is a good place to be but
Scotland ultimately is a place where I
want to go you know because that's where
my grandmother's from and it's a
beautiful place we got the mountains and
the and the lakes not nurse nurses
should oh well you might see it if
you're careful so you know um I like to
I like to do accents that's the most
impressive thing I've ever seen I don't
even know you could do that Wow thank
you learning so much thank you